[Music]
but don't come back forward try to try
to keep thing go go go go go go try to
keep things uh more natural
that would be
weird okay let's go all right
so
um I don't want to be back
here I don't I don't care what
so I'm not back here I don't want to be
up here by the wrist I want to be above
the elbow above the elbow you see that
above the
elbow boom and I can start tapping That
Elbow
[Music]
not that top he the outside
too
far not the not the arm above the
elbow do his G and see how I taken that
elbow that way and that goes into the
front
chikaku so he
thrust that hand knif that's what you're
doing
here you
see you're on the
outside you're going to affect his b
boom
okay sides
yes okay so you get there what you're
doing is a circle over
here very
common you're over here and you're like
doing a circle on the
side the technique Ty my
hand this is the circle this here here
is what I'm circling
around on the other
side this
this right here that's what you're
circling
around as a KN I'm not on the side
getting out of the way the knife point
and I
exchange like this so watch how I'm
doing that not out here I just deviating
I'm inside inside
[Music]
okay it's going to
be right at me until I rotate as opposed
to I got off the
line I'm right here and I'm rotating
around the point okay try to this this
part right here this part
don't start so far
away okay you feel it okay go your qua
your elbow are
connected so you get that elbow
com yeah so that percussion in
deflection yeah you're saying that it's
connected to the qua yeah I still feel
kind it goes like this I don't go like
that
he cuz I still feel myself yeah cuz even
on the Ty Hano right I'm T Hano you guys
still go like
that you're not you're not feeling the
power
okay the same exact thing okay so let's
look at the knife again and uh do that
hand here I'm not getting off the line
and then turning over here the potential
thrust point and my target potential
that's what rotates around each other
you get that okay so we're going to do
something slightly
different I'm going to go this way
okay this way not not I'm not doing
this I'm pulling them
in go as
fast as fast I'm not doing this I'm
doing
this I hit
straight
no this
different
circle
circle pull them in you
see not
the
P okay try
so when you guys are going slow you have
to MIM the force quickly so you can't go
like that push my hand that will happen
slow when you went fast you put your
body into it you understand and if she
hits the knife you mov your body
body doesn't move your hand you got it
you want to train slow I don't have a
problem with that but then the UK is got
to pick up and mimic the inertia okay so
on on this next point right
here I pull in I don't want to go way
over here and then here cuz what this
hand is doing targets over here what
this hand is doing is hitting her she's
coming in you understand so you don't
want this to go here she stopped coming
in and then you hit you you get that so
you're
here
boom okay makes sense but it's not this
straight there's that absorption boom in
okay
all right so let's look at
something uh he's coming in okay here
push
on come push
on push
on push on Virginia
that's what see can Str you
understand push on
Virginia that's what's hitting his stro
you understand it's not
this you understand that that throat is
his body is going to go there and that
throat is going over there and there's
no question about okay so if you
go slow you're here you don't want to be
ungrounded look at my feet look at look
over here you
see you have to be
grounded mid foot back here just like
this just like we just doing it D
Dynamic
now okay try
little
more
receiving so this one I came this way I
took the the deviation of tyo I didn't
take the H work of tyo this one's
here you have a very concave chest on
the morning
M and you don't have to hit them
fo came off the
ground and you don't you you got to put
it all together if if you deviate too
far what's going to happen I already
made that correction they're going to go
past they'll go past or they'll stop
that you won't have their opposing force
on your strike which would increase your
impact got it they'll also counter
they'll move they'll do something
because they they fin attack now they
can counter attack your counter but if
you hit them while they're attacking you
they're going to keep attacking you then
you get a free shot okay so watch how
much you deviate but don't under deviate
because if you don't if you get stabbed
that's the end of the technique too okay
try put it together here we go I don't
okay this way he's going to come back
he's going to come
back I don't want you
boom comes back do it
again
boom boom we'll do it again
stop first one the first one here second
one here okay not enough
right boom
dev8 same thing the the potential ATT
attack and the potential
Target are going to rotate around each
other in that's how close I got he touch
my with the tip is what you
want same thing again got right on the
shirt okay get used to that guys see
okay so here's here's where you want to
do right and I don't want to move that
like this it's not going like that it's
going like this got it okay so that was
the first one then the second one here
it is I don't want it to go like
that it's going to circle which way
you
see good not here not there
Circle go
Circle and watch how much go ahead watch
how much closer we're going to be on so
we'll do the first one boom I can barely
reach you you see you do the second one
even
less here
look you see
okay we'll do okay there we are and then
the second one right and a little even
further you
see okay
try don't push his cut down on the first
one and the second target that Sean went
with was the stomach so do the stuff
we're working on
every time you pick you do a different
energy you should have done a different
energy as not yet do you get it if
you're going to cut off you like I'm
going to cut off his big toe and I'm not
going to do a move that guards his
stomach got
it doing weird stuff you're you're
punching with the knife your fist is
going to hit before the knife D it's a
Thrust so you have to point the tip
towards the
stomach just go slow so you can
concentrate
good keep go slow and steady your your
mind is wigging out okay keep tring
I I move then he comes in I move again
can't do anything okay so I move my
target is what I'm doing he goes I move
the target is what I want
okay right this is where all that stuff
is okay I'm in range for everything I
don't want to be here here we're going
to just keep going okay so it's a very
simple
drill here go around come back go around
you can combine your deviation cuz right
that's important but it's in the qua the
qua moved it he comes back the qua is
going to move the qua moves it you see
don't leave your hand there move that
your qual moves okay got to go around
you feel pressure you see this the heel
feel the pressure and that's what goes
around okay try
that means right put weight arches
up yes
yes yes
okay Dan is really
narrow we have two tests
I'm not break dancing okay I
demonstrated slow but when it's fast it
was so subtle that none of you even
noticed it
okay so if it's if it's too
close what should you do with your angle
refle
open the knif Too Close to
You have the question yes what should I
do with my angle
deflection you should see the vertical
plane you
guys not the horizontal point the
vertical plan okay
so you just add that to your movement
you're like way over there I don't know
whatever you got there okay so same
thing I don't want to lower the hand the
body lowers you see and
around right
okay
down so he's he's coming in quite a bit
I don't want to correct him too much cuz
it's good opportunity
right um but you going keep them out how
do you keep them
out
um with the adhesion yes with the
adhesion on the hand first hand on the
throat there's all kinds of ways of
keeping him out so you don't get into
that problem
okay yes just go down he's going to come
up he he's got that that he's freaking
out sorry SAR you're freaking out knif
it's all wicking him out he's he's going
slow so he has all his joint
articulation do you get it we already
addressed that and then he changes his
speed did do you see that okay then none
of that's possible at full speed
whatever you should still feel at your
level that he's going to do that that
he's been doing that you get it that
he's has a tendency to do that all this
be knowable to you and then it should
all be
feelable so that you don't let him cut
you no matter how dorky the
thing is to our training culture there's
no dorkiness to our training culture at
a certain level he's doing what he's
doing you now address whatever he's
doing does that make sense
okay keep doing you s we'll fix you
another day
so what is it what's the
difference I just
address Virginia is staying connected to
what to her whole body when she strikes
Sarah's arm goes sah disconnects do you
see that okay so then that means you
have to
be I have to you have to connect to his
Center through the arm
you get that
okay so something's touching something
right yeah what is it touching is that
your knife hting
or what's the clicking that's my handle
against okay continue then
see she keeps her Center in the knife
okay he's not going to
do don't want to fall you don't want to
get hit you know might not even know how
to do it right that's what
happens see she did it
okay and you should feel what they're
doing cuz when we turn it up you're just
going to be a sack of potatoes that's
going to get hit in the throat and then
crash on the map in your head okay so
you got to learn to maintain
Center because now I shamed you right
okay then here you got his you finding
his Center you see but here you're not
here you're just deflecting so here you
finding you find it's it's already there
it's that Center that allows me when I
that pressure to stay connected to
it you're not going to go here and then
feel that it's going to be too late so
you're find the center I I'm already in
your body you understand it's just that
I don't take advantage of it cuz you're
starting to come back so but I'm in your
body as you start to come back I use
that body make sense okay so as soon as
as soon as you touch whether you touch
here you're in you're in the B okay I'm
touch here I'm in the body I hit here
I'm in the body I'm in the body okay you
come in back I feel
[Music]
it so absorb touch again seem very nice
for me okay War so this is what we're
going to do we feel the body warm watch
how watch how I'm using this now to take
his not his arm his body out you see
that
so connect connect
out then we just add Bo this stri
we're here okay not now not from here
I'm in the body okay and then as you
come back I don't go off I stay on I'm
yielding you see there's the downward
plane and
out I had to go that low cuz you're
disconnecting your AR your center from
your knife as you're going it's fine
okay so I don't want to just go here
it's taking your balance you
see you got it yes so you feel the
center
B not not trying to throw you but I want
you to feel that the kazushi is
there okay all right
so you see how this this is all just
external limb manipulation okay which is
fine but I'll tell you the best way of
learning how to get past that is you
figure out how to connect your lims to
your
Center you get it and that's what you're
not doing now you
can't it's fine we are where we are